[Musique]
la députée de la circonscription du nord
est avec nous dans ce que dit bonjour
manuela kikla on désire non j'en attends
moi j'entends indique m dis moi que vous
avez pris la relève de brute de nestor
azérot à l'assemblée nationale car il
avait choisi de retourner en mairie dix
mois c'est bon vous maîtrisez tous les
rouages de la maison non on ne peut pas
dire qu'on maîtrise tous les mois je
mets en 10 mois j'ai pu on va dire
découvrir les premiers rails à la
première organisation j'ai pu prendre
mes marques
c'est vrai que j'ai pris le l'exercice
en cours donc le contexte était
particulier mais je suis entouré dents
au sein de mon groupe avec mes
parlementaire est évidemment quand on
est une femme politique qui est
suppléante déjà jeu
on s'apprête aussi à prendre le relais
dix mois pour observer assimilés
comprendre et agir et surtout faire
savoir qu'on agit car biais des
martiniquais vous y trouvez plutôt
silencieuse effacés simple impression
réalité c'est peut-être votre trait de
caractère
alors je dirais que ma personnalité
aussi n'est pas de
on va dire de communiquer à tous 20
certes mais je suis pas particulièrement
médiatisé mais pour autant que je
travaille donc voilà je n'ai pas voilà
je suis je suis plutôt dans l'action je
voudrais qu'on communique davantage sur
ce que je fais est pas forcément ma
personne mais je crois que c'est encore
mieux d'être d'être
voilà que la communication voilà non je
ne cherche pas je travaille et dossiers
qui concernent nos parlementaires sont
malheureusement nombreux madame picard
mon désir le des plus sensibles se sont
quand même on en parle de l'actualité
dont la mène sur sur le plateau les
limites maximales de résidus dans la
viande bovine on parle du scandale de la
torre déconne plusieurs associations
viennent d'écrire au président de la
république pour lui dire d'arrêter de
jouer avec la santé des martiniquais du
zéro chlordécone pro final vous êtes
d'accord
oui tout à fait je suis d'accord sur le
respect c'est une question de de santé
publique et ça l'a fait trop trop
longtemps que ça dure et idées il est
temps que nous puissions
offrir à la population martiniquaise et
la population française de manière
générale on va dire des denrées
totalement démuni de pesticides et
d'autres qui m'entourent oui tout
longtemps qu'on en parle mais je crois
je pense que tout le monde observe il
s'agit très souvent de nom quand je dis
qu'on observe voit bien qu'il s'agit de
gossau ya du lobbying qui est qui est
fait mais c'est un aussi parlementaires
et tous les mâts dire les politiques pas
seulement les parlementaires mais c'est
aussi à nous on va dire population
personnalités diverses de de vraiment
maintenir justement cette pression au
niveau du gouvernement et les
associations le font très bien
maintenant ce sont les chinois doivent
doivent en tenir compte également
est-ce que selon vous mais n'implique à
mon désir la martinique c'est
suffisament encore fait suffisamment
peuple pour parler d'une seule voix face
à ce scandale du chlordécone il ya
l'action des associations gars les
prises de position des parlementaires
mais bon il ya la population qui crie sa
souffrance on désespoir sa désespérance
au scandale à tout bout de champ mais on
a l'impression que ce sont des
tentatives dispersé que justement ça ne
marche pas
ce n'est pas une tentative dispersé
maintenant il faut il faut se rendre
compte quand même qu'il y à il ya deux 2
2 on va dire deux volets aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de solution alternative qui
est vraiment proposer à nos agriculteurs
est également et nos éleveurs donc c'est
là la difficulté de l'exercice qui est
ok oui 0 chlordécone
mais comment eux ils font face justement
un set
c'est à ces décisions donc c'est là où
l'exercice est difficile mais nous
devons absolument y arriver parce qu'il
s'agit d'une question de santé publique
l'enjeu c'est de transformer scandale
sanitaire a une autre vision de notre
agriculture de façon produire exiger que
l'état joue son rôle de contrôle
oui tout à fait un autre drame les
sargasses alors dans dans le quotidien
france antilles de lundi vous dites
qu'il faut absolument transformer une
problématique en filière de
développement
oui oui
copé mais aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
le choix nous le subissons
on va dire l'arrivée massive des
sargasses qui régulièrement chaque année
c'est un phénomène sera un phénomène
récurrent
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes bien
obligés de différent face c'est vrai que
le ramassage est une technique mais moi
dès le départ je les indiqué je me bats
jusqu'ici et conflit avec une réflexion
avec le préfet et au niveau du
gouvernement et en disant qu'il faut
donner les moyens de deux jumelles de
deux techniques qui est le ramassage
proches côtier mais une fois que nous
avons ramassé on en fait quoi on va pas
les stocker on a vu un
robert et dans d'autres communes en
stock mais il ya des techniques pour
stocker pour que justement les on va
dire les gaz toxiques ne puisse pas on
va dire
m la population donc nous avons un
phénomène nous avons introduit au lieu
de subir le phénomène je propose qu'on
transforme cela on va dire en atout et à
ce moment là nous avons des dix idées
nous devons faire des appels à projet
pour que des investisseurs puis ça te
montrer sur le secteur martinique avait
un en martinique de manière à ce qu'on
puisse transformer il ya des durs on l'a
vu nous nous sommes très friands de
whatsapp de tout ce qui se fait de
l'extérieur nous avons vu des
possibilités de transformer en va dire
en produits en essence en matière madame
la députée le contenu de petite échelle
le martinet qui même sur la soci la
guadeloupe toute initiative sera risqué
il faudrait investir des sommes
importantes sur une algue je pense que
la martinique ne méritons pas qu'un
effort du gouvernement sera fait pour
que nous puissions transformer et
surtout agir sur la santé publique
développer une filière économique non je
suis à persuader que nous le méritons en
martinique de la même manière que ça
s'est produit dans d'autres régions de
france
il est important que nous puissions
exigé et insisté pour que le
gouvernement puisse faire l'effort pour
la martinique nous n'oublions pas que la
martinique est un ne prenait pas une
épine au pied du on va dire aux pieds de
de la france hexagonale mais c'est un
atout
donc il faut pas seulement puiser il
faut aussi investir trois femmes
parlementaires
manuela mondésir ia josette manin
catherine conconne et vous il y a deux
femmes heures en martinique jeudi du lys
au morne-rouge et marie thérèse casimir
us à basse-pointe il y aura de nouvelles
élections bientôt ça va mieux pour les
femmes en politique
alors je dirais que oui on voit de plus
en plus de femmes s'investir c'est vrai
que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas arrivé
comme ça par la volonté des hommes
c'est depuis 2001 effectivement la loi
sur la parité qui a aussi favorisé cela
maintenant je suis pas particulièrement
friands que ce soit une loin qu'il aime
pause mec plutôt que ce sont des femmes
qui
qui décide de s'investir et s'engage en
politique
bon ces deux c'est une évolution au fur
et à mesure je suis persuadé que 2020
sera aussi un tournant on nous verrons
certainement plus de candidates
tête de liste femmes têtes de liste et
je les encourage parce que je suis
persuadé aussi que le regard de la femme
là les méthodes et la conception de la
gestion publique de la gestion de d'une
collectivité notamment communal et
aura un autre dira un autre regard gérée
par des femmes
alors là vous me tendre la perche à vous
avez créé votre mouvement assez joseph
nouvelle alternative citoyenne vous
préparez déjà le terrain pour 2020 dans
un an un an et demi à peu près je ne
prépare pas seulement le terrain j'ai
toujours été sur le terrain
j'ai toujours été sur le terrain j'ai
été conseillère municipale je suis
conseillère municipale jeu j'étais
conseillère régionale je suis député je
suis partie particulièrement attaché au
terroir au territoire je dis que c'est
le terrain qui nourrit donc je suis j'ai
toujours été présente maintenant pour
voilà j'organise on va dire à la
conscience mardi joséphine autour autour
de la question municipal et il est
important pour moi de d'organiser des
choses mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles
sont du même bord politique
athanase jeanne rose le maire actuel de
saint joseph qui alors derrière on ne
sait pas exactement ce qui s'est passé
mais lors des voeux à l'association des
maires il aurait dit que 2020 se ferait
sans lui je l'appelais personnellement
il m'a dit il faut pas écouter tout ce
qu'on raconte
il ya une sorte de flou concernant c'est
joseph c'est le sait le champ de tous
les possibles
mais je sais pas je ne sais pas la neige
a le droit je n'ai pas discuté non plus
à l'est et donc
non on n'a pas eu à discuter de cela
maintenant la décision lui appartient et
au moment venu il fera clairement il
fait et fera clairement élections même
si lui vie retourne alors aujourd'hui je
suis dans je suis au conseil municipal
je suis conseillère municipale au sein
de la majorité je me suis engagé à ses
côtés effectivement pour porter ma
contribution à voir on va dire une
nouvelle dynamique n'oublions pas que si
on observe la moyenne d'âge du conseil
municipal actuellement est plutôt autour
de 63 ans donc je pense que le voilà il
faut mix beaucoup plus plus important
pour qu'on puisse vraiment venu une
politique municipale dynamique mais pour
l'instant je n'ai pas dit je n'ai pas de
définir quelle suite nous est vraiment
quelques secondes
l'ami de votre ami et co président
deux nouveaux mouvements politiques pays
a très rapidement vous pourriez y
adhérer la vie de votre âme il s'agit de
jean phi denis lors amis de vous pouvez
dire mon ami également siégeant au
groupe gdr ensemble à l'assemblée
nationale c'est ça aussi le je dirais
l'apport féminin aux dents dans cette
radiant dans le paysage politique c'est
nous pouvons être des amis sans
forcément être dûment politique du même
bord politique
maintenant je salue une initiative merci
beaucoup manu lakic l'ardent désir
député de la martinique merci d'envoyer
ce matin dans son crédit bonne journée